do you remember we kind of stated this
we kind of stand it unequivocally we
just said yeah it'll always work right
it's always worked for us for
differentiation right but doesn't really
always work nish let's have a look at
this right let's let's think of some
examples on n right and will they
actually work right well if we say let's
try thinking about this now I'm
deliberately writing it in a form that
doesn't make it immediately apparent
like okay what am I supposed to do with
this
okay it's not a polynomial which is
actually critical how do I write that in
index for this yeah this is X to the
power of negative one okay now if I
think oh that's okay
it's an X to the power of n so I'll just
I'll just do the thing I did right I'll
book the power up and then I'll divide
by oh oh right now you can see therefore
you can see that for right in fact they
say um there's a particular case for
this you must say you must say except X
cannot equal it can equal negative one
doesn't work for that now what's
interesting is okay I found the case
where it doesn't work is it because
there's a negative power of it is that
the problem it doesn't take that much to
verify or disprove whether this is a
problem why don't we try another power
let's try the derivative being X to the
power of negative two this is one on x
squared right does it what let's just
give it a shot right I'm going to
increase the power which gives me minus
1 just watch out for that you know how I
said always shifting gears right a very
common error is to say oh it's a - I
don't get it increased - it turns into
three oh wait okay that's that's
reducing the parts getting smaller not
bigger
so I've increased the power and then
what I do / days once in this is my
answer okay
now does it what does it work
so this is um this is this right now
you've got two ways to know I need
another color
you've got two ways to know that we have
it's good enough we did it exactly right
in fact this rule at this adds a
differentiation rule it works for every
case except for that one but everywhere
else okay let me quickly illustrate for
you why we know that this is the case of
the first way is just this of going
through this process right but doing it
the normal way just differentiate that
big minus 1 1 X plus the closet what
happens in the closet disappears as
you'd expect right what happens to the
minus 1 over X now we're in
differentiation birth right you've got
to shift gears shift keys you bring
their minus 1 out the front which
cancels yeah thumbs up and then you
reduce the power by 1 which gives us the
minus - it all looks good ok now we can
really really confirm I saying hold on
ok I know what these things are we've
done a whole load of these right what
does what does this guy look like what
kind of graph is it has a name such an H
it's a hyperbola right it's not an
ordinary hyperbola that you're used to
it's the ordinary hyperbola flipped
upside down ok cuz there's that minus
sign right so I'm normal hyper blurs
here and here so the hyper now I'm gonna
be interested in this here and here okay
close for a second
now this is why a graph of dy on
DX right at least it's one of them no
sorry this is my real function that's
where I've ended up this is one of the
primitives ok
now what does this graph look like this
is the derivative you shouldn't go
upside down ok
- whatever I swear what kind of function
is it it's got some symmetry it does
right it's an even function ok so this
is my graph of wine these my graph of dy
on
DX ok because I've got one over experian
experts always gonna be positive right I
accept the zero but that's a discord
you see don't worry about it so
therefore sits x squared is positive 1
over x squared is also positive like the
reciprocal of a positive number is
itself positive does that make sense
so in fact the graph you're getting is
this guy and you've got mass into there
nothing to him you can go ahead and
check why okay now does that make sense
is this the derivative obvious and you
bet it is right look I'll get out my
green for gradient and I'll say tell me
increasing or decreasing increasing
isn't what's going on right it's going
up it's going towards infinity right
that's what I wanted to do now I have a
look at this branch is it increasing or
decreasing it's still going up right
increasing increasing prison but it's
slowing down and it's going towards
Europe because this asymptotes here as
well right so not only algebraically can
you confirm yeah chips out but visually
it's geometry that you know of you can
also confirm it okay and going back to
that it's really powerful I can
encourage you to do that there's a
reason why this is where the top it goes
okay